بعد سنوات من العداء المرير الذي تجاوز
عقدا من الزمن تحرك الروسي يهدف لعقد لقاء
بين الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ورئيس
النظام السوري بشار الاسد
مصادر دبلوماسيه
عقد لقاء مصالحه بين الجانبين تفاديا
لعمليه عسكريه في سوريا لان موسكو مشغوله
في حرب كبيره في اوكرانيا المصادر نفسها
تؤكد ان مساعي روسيا لترتيب اللقاء تنطلق
من يقينها من خطوره عمليه العسكريه
باعتبارها مصدر تهديد خطير للاستقرار
الاقليمي وحتى الدولي المصادر المحت الى
دور ايراني خفي يدفع الاسد لمقاومه ضغط
موسكو فطيران تخشى من نجاح روسيا بخلق
وفاق بين الاسد وارضان ينعكس سلبا على
مصالحها في سوريا
محللون اشاره الى ان طهران تدرك مخاطر
القيام بهذه العمليه على نفوذ كماليه
العراق وسوريا ما دفعها للدخول بتفهمات
عسكريه واضحه مع حزب العمال الكردستاني
وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه لتامين الوصول
الى المتوسط العلاقات بين اردوغان والاسد
تازمت منذ دلاع الصراع في سوريا في عام
2011 انذاك اعلنت انقره دعمها مقاتلي
المعارضه في حين رد النظام السوري اتهام
تركيا بدعم الارهاب فضلا انت وغولات
عسكريه متكرره في شمالي سوريا
بلال البوجداني العربيه